light infantry patrols relentlessly and
aggressively
ambushes the enemy light infantry
sometimes double times into battle
think about that you're like hey we're
running
we're running that's an interesting
thing
i'm concerned i'm a little bit concerned
if i have to run to get to the battle
i'm a little bit concerned about what
i'm doing
because i'm running i feel like i'm late
and if i have to run to battle i feel
like i'm late
yeah it seems like that's like a flex
move
as well concur yeah yeah yeah it's sort
of like
will run yeah yeah i'm not sure if
that's the smartest thing
i'm running that means i'm late and now
i'm tired when i show up yeah a little
bit more
i mean i'm not saying you can't function
i'm saying you're a little more tired
than you would have been
do we get a cool flex right yeah do we
get to say look we'll run
yeah we'll look yeah we'll run maybe
like because it could have been
it could be i guess under certain
circumstances be like a psychological
warfare situation because in football
that's how it was where it's like hustle
off the field hustle on the field right
yeah when you think about okay there
might be a time saving element to that
for sure
but bruh if i'm really not hustling on
and off the field i got more energy for
the play
yeah i'll tell you what when you run
when when like you see
kids wrestling yeah and one kid runs
like they go out of bounds one kid runs
back runs back
neat you know toe on the line ready yeah
and the other kids 100
psychological warfare yeah psychological
warfare
maybe that's why they're saying that
maybe i think you're right i think it
might be in the parlance of our time
a little flex
light infantry tracks listens locates
cuts off raids and
ambushes the enemy isn't that weird to
think about
when you're in when you're competing
against someone
you actually should think you should be
tracking listening locating
cut off raiding and ambushing them think
think about how
the thing that i like about that is
you're focused on them the thing i don't
like about it is you're focused on that
right there's a little dichotomy there
we can't be focused so much on what the
other guy's doing
we need to be doing something
the enemy never knows where the light
infantry is or
when he will attack jack don't give away
your position for the 50 millionth
time i'm not gonna
st when when echo has a different
viewpoint than me i don't start off by
telling him
my viewpoint and explaining why my
viewpoint is better i don't i actually
ask more questions about your viewpoint
and try and understand your viewpoint
and get your viewpoint till i actually
know exactly where it is
before i reveal my position
standing operating procedures are used
widely by light forces
for quick silent action yes standard
operating procedures
for silent action that means you don't
have to talk we know what's going to
happen
next one rehearsals training
pre-combat briefings and sharing of
information
to the lowest levels are more common
among light forces this is the
cornerstone of decentralized command
rehearsals training pre-combat briefings
all that stuff the infiltration of large
units
of light infantry is possible in close
terrain and is necessary for success in
major operations under these conditions
light forces infiltrate to attack the
rear to establish blocking positions
and to create obstacles in the path of a
retreating enemy
yeah check
what that means is where we're moving
into good positions and we're doing it
in a clandestine manner so the enemy
doesn't know that
what we're doing and the last one for
offense is hand-to-hand combat is a
required skill
for the light infantry affirmative
man the the propagation of hand-to-hand
combat right now
in the last since the ufc started is
insane yeah
it's insane yeah yep
it is i mean even in
that community it it's insane not to
mention like
when you go when you explore the
spectrum of the guy who doesn't know
anything versus the guys
the guys or guy who knows a lot
even within the people of who knows
it's so much like variety so it's so
vast you know it
is it is a insane
evolution in since 1993 it's crazy
the evolution since 1993. since the
ultimate fighting championship
yeah the evolution of combat sports is
almost incomprehensible yeah because
before then
it's kind of like people didn't really
have a valid found or a
stable we'll say or reliable foundation
of fighting
and then kind of jujitsu kind of
essentially provided that yeah and
everyone started learning it so what
does it look like this is kind of the
answer the the answer to this question
is what you're talking about
like what does it look like when
everyone knows the foundation imagine
what you can build on it you know
yeah and i guess there's other things if
you look at basketball
right i mean basketball now
is different than it was in 1954
right it's a different game i mean we're
talking
it's a different game but i think that's
less
obviously i think mixed martial arts is
might be the most but
skateboarding you've seen what a kid
will do on skateboards right now
yeah it's crazy it's mind-boggling yeah
surfing
i mean surfing is nuts it's
nuts what guys are doing from a
technical level
from a technical blasting heirs like
what
but not only that blasting 360
ollie airs where they're not even
they're not touching their board but
they're going up and doing a 360 in the
air
and landing it if you brought an
old-school
surfer from 1962 yeah
and you if you were to bring it if you
were to bring a 1962 surfer
and say hey if you go back to 1962 and
said do you think
that a surfer will be able to launch off
the wave
into the air turn 360 degrees without
touching his board
and land does that sound possible
do you know what i mean does that sound
does that actually sound possible
yeah it doesn't re it's kind of hard to
it's kind of hard to comprehend that
that could be an actual thing
yeah you know they probably wait what do
you mean not touch the boards meaning
not grab that board
they didn't even understand grabbing the
board like you wouldn't probably have to
say that part
yeah like how are you going to get a
board out of the water first of all
their board weighs 42 pounds
made a redwood
makes it hard so there's these like you
said there's a foundation once this
foundation gets created
you get to build on it and what's that's
what's so crazy i've been talking about
this on the debrief a little bit i've
been talking about ef online
leadership there's a base there but
people just ignore it
yeah people think they don't understand
that leadership is a skill just like
just like surfing just like
skateboarding just like
playing basketball it's a skill and if
you learn
then you if you pick up a book and you
read you'll learn about it and you go oh
i can use these moves
yeah and people don't do that people
people don't understand
why it's very difficult for people to
understand that leadership is a skill
even though they go that guy's a great
leader they think that that person was
just born that way
they don't think what are they actually
doing
i mean when i when i was running the
training
and i got to watch that's what made it
so obvious i'm like oh
that guy's not doing what that other guy
did and that's why they're falling apart
right now
got it
check